okay guys it's show time have a great game Telly
southernland with the appropriate start to this
one Seth Jones at the top of the power play Bard
gave it back to him Taylor Hall over from Boston
himself a former number one overall pick in 2010
looking for a tip from Ryan denado badart briskly
across a rebound for Donado after a shot right
on by Hall was kicked out by Tristan jari kiny
made the team at age 19 Ellers out of the box
four shots on goal good Zone time for Chicago
on that goodlooking power play L Tang Threw
It on net the Penguins think it was in on the
redirect and they might take a look at this for
the moment it's not a goal but here's an icing
call and the officials are going to get together
look I heard how the year went lat Tang throws
this to the net the tip by rust goes up over
Peter morazzi shoulder 20 goals last year for
the fourth straight year he didn't like the year
though Sean now he's got one and the pens are on
the board go line we have a Pittburgh he's on the
board early and the other member of that line is
gel here's Crosby to the backand it's stopped by
morazzi great chance for Sydney Crosby as that
Top Line stayed out for Pittsburgh kachuk threw
it out in front it's tipped wide now part of the
revamp by Kyle DUIs the new president of hockey
operations not a remarkable job in a short time
down low a big stop by morazzi with the left pad
by morazzi here's a malan what a feed as it goes
past tenori and Kaiser look at this flat right
on the tape G wants to get it right up top last
time we saw him he was skating around the ice
with the Stanley cuff as one of the assistant
captains one of the best players in the history
of the golden knights another chance for rubs and
mazic had it come free for a moment and then
he was able to smother incoming goenda moric
for the first time in his career the oldest
goalie on the roster comes flying out of his
crease to make the stop on rasu deflected now
Hall off Escape rebound Bard had a great chance
the puck is free in the crease but the whistle
stops the play get a stick on it so this one
is released so quickly now Bard comes jumping
in for the rebound and Jory makes two stops on
him his vision that something Great's going to
happen all the time and every shift it won't but
that last shift when he had the couple of shots
and the rebound chance is release is so special
it's it's hard to to ignore it we thought in that
first period there's gensel down low had to deal
with a sliding Seth Jones and it's smothered by
Peter morazzi cut out for him here as he handles
the defense Gro for Chicago and it's very young
here's Malin bouncing Pucket another glove save
by morazzi middle of the ice to Raquel but the
puck goes too far and it's right on the tape of
Riley Smith Stanley Cup with Tampa Bay now in his
third year here with Chicago Kaiser put it on that
rebound three for Johnson and jari did a great job
to extend the left leg Tristan jar has been sharp
to a deflection save and a rebound save on Tyler
Johnson to keep the Penguins lead Midway in the
second it's wonderful that they had that time
together at the media day obviously they made
an instant connection as Mike Sullivan said you
know there's no greater Ambassador for hockey
than Sydney Crosby here's rust this Top Line
pressuring again for Pittsburgh centered by
Crosby Crosby Center for gel back for s the kid
he's [Applause] [Music] scores the Penguins start
cycling the puck around the zone and Crosby
takes the return feed from gensel back after
ankle surgery kept them out for all a training
camp and Crosby who missed the deflection and
a rebound moments earlier threads the needle
through Alex vasik pass Peter morazzi Chicago
was using a coach's challenge to determine if
the play was offside prior to the scoring of the
goal we lose sight of the puck for a second there
yeah from there it looks like it might have gone
out after review the play has been confirmed
to be on side the goal will count Chicago is
assessed a v minor delay game penalty back for
blasic Bard Nifty pass for blasic with a lot
of room he put it on at rebound goal Ryan Donado
has Chicago on the board and Conor Bard's got his
first national Hockey League point he'll have an
assist on the pass the blasic the rebound bounces
Odin Ryan Donado 30 goals the last two years in
Seattle the rebound and put it away the pens are
on the ice a long time they're a little slow
there's the pass from Bard the shot the save
the rebound and Donato's cut the lead in half
and Connor Bard and his National Hockey League
debut has a point on the board and D long pass
to Donado sent back by Rael malin's Ry Smith in
denied at Point Blank Range by morazzi yikes that
was a point they're going to have to get somebody
on his line that can take face off but this is
such an he W one there you go on Q vard's got
his first win against Crosby Jones trying to with
it along the line got rid of it before aari could
pick it off now it's taken back by Hall down
low for Perry denied at Point Blank Range by
jari kachuk drops it back Anu had it the flect
off ell Jones in deep centers Gutman scores Cole
Gutman has tied it at two with 955 to go back
in 2017 he played four years at the University
of Denver he's got a scoring touch and here he
is right in the slot he's found that soft spot
you see drewel Conor couldn't get back the pass
is on the tape oh that was close to going right
back onto Donado stick frantic action here in
the third period Dickinson tried to side step
ell scooped up by rust and then he got stopped by
Jones Felino tries to speed the other way Perry
trying to catch up with him Cory Perry it's def
Flex off Crosby and they score the puck went right
to Dickinson and Chicago has the lead with 431
to go but Perry and Felino both brought in here
to be mentors for Conor Bard and show work ethic
and kind of lead by example they combine a lucky
bounce that goes right to Dickens and you see that
great shot from our cameras catches the edge of
the glove of Tristan jari and the Blackhawk here
and nobody moving all that briskly in the corner
it came fre to Felino with the empty net Nick
Felino missed the net the C the Perry out in
front and they score a tip in for Felino and the
Blackhawks are up 4 to2 with 127 remaining but
his feet Hit the Floor out of bit he played with
Nick feno's dad Mike when Luke Richardson was a
rookie in and then he played Luke Richardson told
us his parents were going to get an apartment they
so we don't want to be premature we're going to
wait to make sure he makes it Luke Richards said
he's going to make the team and Richardson Bard
and the Hawks an impressive win on opening night